hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the interesting aspects of
temperance or moderation that many
people I suspect don't think about that
Cicero discusses explicitly in book one
of his treatise on stoic ethics on
duties has to do with house building and
furnishing now this may be seen by many
as not really applying to them this is
only for the the elite or for
householders those who can actually
afford it and the way that Cicero does
describe it would give you that
impression because he asked the question
what sort of house should a person of
rank and ona wrought to somebody who's
being honored somebody was being
elevated and station brink Epps what
sort of house should that sort of person
have now this can actually apply to all
the rest of us if we think about the
general principles involved and how it
is that we we spend and expend you might
say for example I'm shooting this in a
loft apartment right now I'm not a
householder I am a renter and you can
see you know what I'm doing here we've
got a station set up where I can shoot
with the chalk board I can definitely
tell you that we don't have more space
than we we possibly could use which is
something that Cicero is going to talk
about so how we how we rent or build or
purchase and then what we do with the
places that we live this is this really
can't apply if not to everybody at least
far more broadly than Cicero originally
intended and the general principles that
he sets out I think are very useful so
let's take a look at those he says that
when we're considering this question
what sort of house or what sort of
dwelling should a person he has he says
there's three key
things to keep in mind and this is
before he starts giving examples and
rules one is what's in in Latin uses use
or enjoyment translated here is
serviceability which is not being how
well laid-out
is the place you know do you have doors
opening and closing into each other I've
lived in places like that you know is it
is it well-lit is it well set up you
know that serviceability convenience
komoti toss this is a word that gets
used a lot in Latin not just in Cicero's
time but all the way through the Middle
Ages and it means the kind of goods that
we enjoy right it's it's closely
connected with this OSIS and then
distinction Dignitas the word that we
get dignity from these are three things
that Cicero thinks we want to keep in
mind and then he starts giving us some
ideas some rules for how we ought to
understand that and he draws on some
examples from his own time I think that
we can come up with many of our own
examples and I leave it to you to do
that to think of specific cases of
people who you might say go too far and
and notice that Cicero doesn't really
talk about issues of people depriving
themselves or you know having too small
of a house for themselves we usually
tend to go in the other direction people
buy as we say more house than they
really can use or even afford and one of
the things that Cicero says and this is
about halfway through the discussion
that I think is really quite important
he's got this dictum the owner should
bring honor and that's honesta
to honesta to the house not vice versa I
think there's a lot of people in
Cicero's time and also in our own time
who think that the sign that they have
really made it within their society will
be when they can buy the proverbial big
house on the hill
or you know some some fancy condo in you
know an important city like LA or San
Francisco or Chicago or or New York pick
wherever else you want right they think
that real estate translates into real
virtue if you want to quite another
phrase for that and Cicero says that
that's not the case at all because look
we can find all sorts of people who
thought that by engaging in building
projects they would show everybody in
the society that they were decent people
when actually they were scumbags or at
least problematic and so he says you
know a house can bring some dignity to a
person but it's can't borrowed right
it's it's so long as they hold on to
that property it's something external
but it really can't bring an honor in
any real sense the the meaning there
being you know genuine goodness a house
doesn't make you any better of a person
so the honor of the house really derives
from the person who owns it possesses it
builds it uses it I mean think about how
people brag about you know George
Washington slept here of her nights in a
particular in or somebody famous eight
in a particular restaurant we associate
these things and the restaurant isn't
necessarily good you know and then and
then because it was good George
Washington became good no George
Washington was presumed to be an
important guy and he ate there so so we
want to think about things in those
terms
and he says you know we've got plenty of
examples he's got this great case where
Ganesh Octavius built an attractive and
imposing house on the Palatine and then
this other guy sourest demolishes it and
built an addition to his own house and
scour us actually brought disgrace and
ruin upon himself by doing this so
building won't necessarily make you
an important person now another rule
that he gives that's really important
has to do with size and this should be
thought about not just in terms of
public business but in terms of family
gatherings or entertaining or the kind
of work that you're doing you know for
example as an academic I need some
library space and I need some some
workspace like this so we we had to
think you know about an extra bedroom in
essence or you know if we know that
we're gonna be having people over we
have to think about where we're gonna
put them and Cicero talks about this in
terms of other people saying a man must
have regard not for himself alone but
for others all other others also so in
the home of a distinguished person in
which numerous guests many many people
must be entertained in crowds of every
sort of people received care must be
taken to have its spacious so if you
know that you're going to be engaging in
large-scale events well you have to have
a great room or you have to have some
other spacious place where people can
meet so it doesn't feel cramped and why
because you're thinking about the
experience of the other people involved
by contrast he says if you're not doing
that sort of thing you don't need that
much space and he talks about how it's
kind of sad to find these people who are
living just by themselves in these giant
mansions where they have you know more
baths well he doesn't talk about this
but examples we could use more bathrooms
than people and you know wings of the
house that they don't actually use or
explore
he says there's something wrong there
and he even brings up a proverb which
was old in his own time
oh good house alas how different the
owner who now oneth thee so you see
these people who buy a famous person's
house who was doing a lot of
entertaining and they're not doing that
and you look at him you're like well
that's kind of kind of sad isn't it
so that that's an important thing to
think about as well appropriate size
then he talks about something that I
think all of us can relate to because
depending on where we live
size may not be much of an an issue
because we don't have an awful lot of
options but how do we decorate how do we
furnish what do we fill the house with
this is really an interesting question
and he says that we ought to remain
within as he calls it proper limits of
moderation with respect to expense what
we're purchasing slumped uh in Latin and
then it's translated here as display but
I'm just going to translate it as
magnificence because the latin word is
magnifique entia and this is the same
thing as what you know earlier
philosophers like say Aristotle we're
talking about with the virtue of
magnificence when you have a significant
stake within a community how you you
know expend your resources whether they
be time money labour on a large scale
that has to do with magnificence and so
if you think about you know when you
have your party and you have people come
over are you you know directing them to
the the plush carpet that you just
installed you know and telling them how
it's top-of-the-line and then you know
having them sit on your your new $10,000
couch and watch the big-screen TV well
if you if you do if you're doing that
this or let's say you're kind of a
show-off and you're probably exceeding
these proper boundaries and we could
think of all sorts of other ways in
which people attempt to turn their
houses into something like a live-in
museum let's call her right where they
have the most special things in the
world this is something that Cicero
talks about in other places as well for
example in the stoic paradoxes because
this was a major issue in his time not
not least because all these spoils of
we're coming in from from wars that the
Romans were having so they were flushed
with all sorts of luxury items and
people were constantly vying with each
other to show off how important they
were through what we nowadays call
conspicuous consumption I mean this
could extend to what you're serving
guests you know
are you breaking out the super expensive
champagne every time somebody comes over
well then you're probably kind of a
show-off you're not really magnificent
you're vulgar Cicero and and Aristotle
would say so what would it be then to
exercise temperance would it be to say
oh well I'm gonna get you know the
cheapest stuff available no that
wouldn't be temperate either instead you
would want things that are of high
quality but durable and perhaps passed
down you would keep it within proper
limits you wouldn't go as we say hog
wild that's a beautiful expression isn't
it that with the implication being and
it was going and indulging in in sensual
tastes a little bit too far you would
you would try to keep everything within
proper limits and thereby you would show
good taste and you would exercise the
virtue of temperance
you